i think the easiest way to structure
operations
is first list out the things the desired
outcomes that need to happen
i don't get a lot of questions about
operations they just become obvious that
they are a problem within a lot of the
people that
that we help serve and so it's
interesting because now that we
work on the allen side with resellers
it's very clear who's good at operations
and who is not
and that is typically based on the size
of the business the people who are
better at operating are the ones who
make more money
um and this is kind of one of the the
unspoken secrets of the entrepreneurial
world especially within the internet
space that we live in now it appears to
be all about
marketing and sales and legion and
acquisition
and although those are very important
things and you have to start there
it becomes very clear that typically the
entrepreneur has that promotion
type of character traits
and doesn't dedicate the time
to study the operational components of
the business which typically are the
reasons that someone is or is not
successful
and so i wanted to give you at least my
simple
mental framework for how i think about
operations in general
and scaling operations and so for the
vast majority of people listening here
um you're probably under eight figures
um
some are under seven uh but most people
are listening this are probably business
owners in the
multiple uh 100 000 a year to you know
several
several million a year and so for that
so this is who i'm talking to within
that context
i think the easiest way to structure
operations
is first list out the things the desired
outcomes that need to happen
all right and i think of business very
much as a pipeline which is
from click to close to resell right and
resell within different businesses can
be retaining them so that they pay again
or it could be a variation of ascension
but when i say click it means
how do i get someone to click and that's
just within the internet environment
click
to opt-in to schedule to show to buy
to then ultimately want to buy again and
so
uh if you have like with our gyms a
four-step sales process or three-step
sales process that's happening
there are clear activities that need to
happen right
and so in the beginning you will have
your front-end sales and so you need to
list that as one of the activities right
because the objective would be to sell
them
the activity is to take the call next
you'd have the
nutrition orientation which would be the
next time you'd meet with them
so then you need to allocate how many of
those
you're going to need based on your
current inflow it's the nice thing is is
that there's a ratio
of for every 10 customers we need to do
four of these two of these two of these
in one of these right and so what you
can do is once you realize what the
outcomes are
you can list out all of the activities
that are required so for a typical
client we might know that
it takes about two minutes per client
per day and if we know that a coach has
three hours uh like we want to say
winner kappa coach at 100
then we know that that coach is going to
be able to do that within
x amount of time right and so then we
book that time
on that person's day and so what happens
is
what you should do when you're creating
your company is when you're creating
each of the roles that are going to
support you
you need to look at a calendar and look
at what the times of day that this
person is going to be working and what
they're going to be doing with each hour
of their day
and so you simply take the activities in
the allocated time
that they need to work and place those
on their calendar
and that's honestly all there is to it
all right so i'm going to give you an
example to hopefully flesh this out a
little bit
but within uh within an online fitness
business which many of you guys are
operating right now
um there's really four
if if demand gen is being taken care of
right so if legion is being taken care
of and lead nurture is being taken care
of and i'm saying that because
uh it'll make the example simpler but
also because that's what we do in our
company
for gyms is uh if those two things are
taken care of
then there's really not a lot that needs
to happen right
so first you need to have first sales
calls right to get new customers
talking to prospects then you need an
onboarding all right that onboardings be
typically a nutrition orientation and
also walking through the app and the
tech and the things that need to happen
um and and that's it right
uh the third thing that will need to
occur will be some sort of
ascension conversation which is gonna
sell them into continuity
all right so that's number three now
every customer is going to have one of
these things
right and so if you're selling here it
is you're selling 10 people a week then
you need
to if you're going to if you're going to
maintain that flow then
if you know that your front end sale is
30 minutes your nutrition appointment is
30 minutes and then your ascension is 30
minutes
then for every client that you're
bringing in you have an hour and a half
per week that's going to be allocated
right now you can divide that up between
different people
but the keys to scaling is that
eventually it becomes too much for one
person to do all of those activities
and then you start blocking entire
pieces of that type of activity to the
next person
right and so i'm going to continue with
the example
after that the only other activity
that's going to be there
would be uh either recruiting coaches
right
and obviously the fulfillment and so uh
let's say that the average customer is
going to take
five minutes today i said two earlier
but let's just say it's five minutes
today right
and somebody has uh uh whatever it is
five minutes is a lot let's say say two
for math's sake
so 200 minutes if you had 100 clients
per day is what's going to be allocated
so that's
what it is three three hours and you
know
20 minutes so you look at someone's
schedule now that's obviously in a
perfect scenario
um but i'd look at one of my coaches
schedules and say okay we're going to do
90 minutes in the morning and we're
going to do 90 minutes in the afternoon
and we're going to block those times out
so just like that we had eight hours a
day now i have five hours left
what else do i want this person to do
well i probably want them to take the
onboarding
conversations with the new customers who
are coming in right this is a coach
and i know that if we generate 10 new
customers a week
on average then that's going to take
five hours
per week which means i can block one to
two hours a day for that and be
totally fine right so i might block now
this is where availability becomes
interesting because
if you just do it at noon every day the
new customers might not be able to make
that time
right and so i might have uh you know
slots on monday wednesdays and fridays
uh at one time and then tuesdays and
thursdays at another time and that way
it gives them some
uh different times to select from right
but again
we have our daily activities uh now that
you know for that coach is going to be
the fulfillment that's ongoing
uh we might also have them do the
nutrition orientation which would be
an hour or two hours per day right
so if we have an hour let's say an hour
per day so now we've got four of their
eight hours
that have been taken now we've got four
more hours
that can be used by this person so now
we have options
do we want this person to create content
do we want this person to do outreach do
we want this person to
uh gosh i mean
whatever i mean do we want to expand
this person's capacity right
so there's or we would know that this
person's currently at
50 utilization now if you flip that and
then think well maybe this person can
take some of the exit meetings right so
this is
uh maybe this person can take some of
the content now this is strategic
questions not operational questions but
i'm saying this is how you structure it
operationally
it's like okay if we're selling 10
people a week then we need to have uh
10 halfway conversations where we're
going to send them into continuity
and then we'll also maybe have
transformation meeting which is the end
where we take the pictures and all that
kind of stuff
so we know each of those meetings takes
another 30 minutes each per customer
if we know that we get 10 new customers
per week then we know that's going to be
another
hour so 10 hours per week total so
that's another two hours per day
assuming that they're working five hours
a week
and so now we're at six hours per day of
work
all right now that's if someone's being
perfectly efficient i would still
expect people to be perfectly efficient
because i think you don't you get what
you tolerate
um and so that would be six hours a day
for a coach
now at that point this coach is handling
uh
basically everything posts the initial
sale right they're managing the ongoing
fulfillment
they're managing the onboarding
activities for these new customers
and they're managing the back-end uh
meetings with them
uh to convert them into continuity right
and so
all of these things put together uh
would create a role
within the business and so my my my ask
or my recommendation for you
is if you haven't done this activity it
provides you immense clarity in
understanding what are the different
activities that need to
occur in the business to make more money
and then once you have the list of the
activities
then you know how long each of the
activities could take and then the only
variable
that will dictate um how many of them
you have is what your inflow is
right and so if you know what your
inflow is and you know what your base of
customers is and the num
and your attrition you can very
accurately back into
what a an ideal day looks like for each
of the roles within your business
also the bigger you get the more you
will find inefficiencies where
you're starting these partial roles
they're getting full-time pay for
half-time work
right and so this allows you to be more
efficient because you can say hey i know
you're only at 40 utilization why are
you telling me
that you're too busy right now why are
you telling me that i need to hire
another coach
what else are you doing that is not
within these parameters
now if someone then says well i'm doing
this this and this then it's like oh
now either they'll be founded at things
like things that are useful and
you know value producing or they won't
be many times they're not but that's not
because the person
who's who your employee is doing this
out of you know nefarious intentions
they're not trying to be
malicious they're not trying to hurt
your business it's simply because a lot
of people just don't even know it's
valuable
right and so they they're they're trying
to work they're trying to provide value
but
a lot of times they just don't get how
like they just
a lot of times they jump into the bigger
picture or why you're not having someone
do something
right but if the thing that they're
doing is
is a core activity like i gotta check in
on these people i to add them to this
uh it takes this long to get the
documents back or you know sometimes we
have these past
password issues then you can see is this
something that we can fix operationally
within
an additional process or is it something
that we can um
you know either throw out and then get
this person to refocus and then
increase how much work they're doing by
by adding more clients to their roster
etc
and so um all this to say this is how
i've thought about operations is just in
terms of activities and units of time
and then expected inflow and so based on
those three variables of
this is how many people are coming in
these are the activities that need to
happen and this is how long they should
take
then it allows you to account for all
the things that need to happen in the
business and will ultimately allow to
have a more efficiently run
shop now i guarantee you that because of
the headline that i had operations for
dummies this will be one of the least
listened to podcasts out there but it is
the reason
that the people who make the most money
make the most money and i just cannot
tell you
like the amount of people who have
access who have tried to copy our stuff
at gym lunch and
and and are 1 10th 120th the size of
what we are
and uh guys just like it's
it's the boring work it's the it's the
it's the rolling your sleeves up it's
the repetitive
work it's the meetings and training your
team on improving how good they are
doing the things that is ultimately the
thing that's going to
propel a company and those things are
based on culture and tolerance of the
leader
and so um i just want to leave you with
that so if you feel like you're
constantly overwhelmed and you don't
feel like you have transparency into
what your people are doing you're like
what are they doing all day
this is the activity that you can do
that will give you immense clarity and
transparency to what their actions are
so you can also restructure the business
to make the most money and also
find inefficiencies or additional tasks
that you're not accounting for that they
are doing which are either revenue
generating
or requirements or they're totally
worthless activities that they're simply
doing because they just don't know any
better
and so um highly recommend doing it and
if you don't know where to start
the easiest thing to do is have your
employees take a time study
all right so a time study is very simple
you have an excel sheet you have every
15 minutes of the day
and then you just have them write down
what they did for each of those 15
minutes now they're going to think
that's going to take a lot of time
you are never more efficient than when
you do a time study i probably every
time i do one i tell myself i'm going to
do it again
like forever and then i don't but but
you will literally be more efficient in
your work than you ever will because you
know that you're being held accountable
to it
all right so um it's like whenever layla
and i need to go and take a close look
at apartment the first thing we do
like these numbers aren't adding up this
feels weird this feels heavier this
feels light whatever it is
we go we ask them to times today for a
week and then we look
at their activities you can also very
quickly see where there's [ __ ] right
where people are like ah
responding to emails i'm like why do you
have three hours of emails
is there something i don't know about
how long does it take to reply to email
how many emails are you getting every
day
and so that's how you can start peeling
the layers back and seeing if someone's
being dishonest which
happens right and they're doing it
because they want to keep their job and
i get that but
that being said it's not useful for the
business and so um
that is how if you want to get a
baseline of like okay well now i know
what all the activities are
you can deem whether they're valuable or
not and you can deem whether you want
them to keep doing it or whether they're
expanding their time
uh sorry expending their activities to
meet the amount of time that they're
supposed to be working
all right so um that is my my quick uh
that's that's kind of my mental
framework for how i look at operations
um and how to uh structure them for
different roles within the company
is first look at the the outcomes that
you want the activities you need to
generate
uh that that outcome how long those
activities take per customer per unit
and then you can extrapolate out based
on the volume based on the inflow what
each role needs to do and then at what
points
you will have breaking points where
somebody will become overwhelmed and you
need to create a new role
all right so um anyways i hope that was
valuable for you hope that made sense
otherwise have a happy thursday uh happy
corona
happy quarantine and i hope you are
adapting because you have no choice but
to do so
otherwise all right lots of love catch
you guys
you